what is the non-natural because i know
when you use the word natural what is
the what can the non-natural do to
increase their market value both men and
women
um as far as sexual market value is
concerned yeah like like you say you're
available you're single okay
and you're in the marketplace right now
and you're like listen maybe you're at
not not at the best place career-wise
you're kind of trying to get it together
maybe you're trying to make a comeback
and maybe you're somebody you're a woman
who is you know 34 years old and you're
single
and your last relationship didn't work
out maybe you're a single mother right
now
and you left your husband or vice versa
right you're by yourself what can that
person do to increase their market value
to be attractive to the opposition
um very easy for men there's
there's three core aspects and really
four if you think about it there's uh
make muscles make money and learn game
and in terms of game i mean like social
skills uh that a lot of guys by the way
are very lacking these days and then as
the fourth part of that is is a whole
frame like so once you have built that
world you know with uh make money make
muscles learn game then you have frame
as a part of that and again this is a
psychological sociological term like
what's the frame right now um and it
doesn't necessarily have to do with just
you know interpersonal relationships it
can be your boss it can be your your mom
or your dad and your family like frame
is like whoever's friend psychological
frame you're entering into or they're
entering entering into yours
so one when we're looking at uh guys
sort of coming back from from being like
okay i'm deficient in these areas most
men when they
when they find what works for them they
gross out in one of those areas so i i
don't make a lot of money i'm kind of
poor but man i can go bench 400 you know
400 pounds
i'm in the 300 club right i can whatever
it is i can i can maximize my looks and
everything at the cost of my deficiency
in say money or even in game we see a
lot of this in black pill communities
right now where they think it's nothing
but looks it's you know to the point
where they're you're doing jaws or size
so they can get a better you know
jawline or doing you know cosmetic
surgery as a result of this
really kind of obsessive uh
misunderstanding that it's all about
it's only about looks okay
so what you would think that these guys
would be like you know uh jim bros or
they would be like personal trainers or
something but that's one area that is if
you're deficient in one of those areas
you tend to gross out another so what i
would suggest is look at which areas you
tend to be really strong at and then
look at where you you tend to be weak at
most guys if they're weak in money they
they tend to gross out on looks if
they're if they're fat and they don't
look very good or they're not naturally
good looking they tend to gross out in
money and say well it's all about the
money and all i have to do is just pay
for everything and girls will want to
come to me and then it's like there's
the game aspect of it well i don't have
either of those but i'm very charming
and so therefore i can you know i know
people's psychology and you tend to
gross out in that area as well my
suggestion to guys is if you want to
have a if you really want to build
yourself up look where you're weak in
those three core three things because
the fourth is to have frame as a result
of all of those three things so if you
are not in good shape which what is it
not 75 of the united states population
is like overweight and like 40 percent
is like morbidly obese that's usually
the best place to start get your fat ass
in the gym that will help you out with
with your uh just not necessarily the
just the looks side of things but it'll
help you feel better because you're
releasing stress and there's a chemical
biochemical aspect that goes along with
that if you're deficient in money people
will say well how do i get on my game
with money uh crypto how do i do how do
i become an entrepreneur how do i um
learn a trade how do i like i'm better
at these things find out what your core
strengths are um primarily if i'm when
i'm telling guys like they've asked me
this question
first and foremost i say what is
sedating you
is it pornography is it booze is it uh
prescription drugs is it your uh and
your addiction to world of warcraft
whatever it is whatever that is sort of
your video games it's a life that is
it's better to live in your escape than
it is in your shitty real life that's
that i think that's the first and
foremost is find out what's sedating you
because you can't address any of those
core three until you decide until you
figure out what's keeping you in bed all
day long and you're not you don't want
it do you think this metaverse concept
is going to help help us
it's fun we've just talked about this um
yeah i think it's gonna i think it's
gonna hurt because it's going to be more
like i think a more immersive experience
right if you're not happy with your life
just go check into the universe good
luck i remember when world of warcraft
and those uh online role-playing games
came out and everybody was you know
neglecting their children because they
were too busy you know trying to level
up if that's human nature imagine what
it's going to be like when we get into
the metaverse and we're already talking
about like you know women are
filing suit against meta for like being
you know sexually assaulted yeah in in
the metaverse right now and you're
already seeing like real world problems
sort of being transferred over into
into the the metaverse like we're
already it's a natural shift over but
yeah i think that that will be an escape
that will be a sedation to keep you
locked in place to keep you in neutral
for women um my my biggest concern with
women and it's funny you brought up you
know what if you're a divorced mom of
five or whatever
and you want to get back into the game
well first and foremost you have to
remember what it is that men are looking
for
and at what what particular age uh i'm
53 years old if i were to find myself
single i'm not going to be looking for a
woman who is say like 25 years old
because i've already gone through that
phase of life i'm mature enough and i
can think critically enough to go you
know what it might be fun you know to to
have a fling with that person but you're
not going to build a life with that
person going a lot of people palm beach
would disagree with you yeah yeah i know
yeah
as far as women are concerned um i think
women need to uh look uh see the force
for the trees right now i don't think a
lot of women
look ahead long term
i work with these guys fresh and fit
which are in in miami here um and you're
probably familiar with them uh they have
one of the number one podcasts and
certainly in southern florida if not you
know dating podcasts over the world
they bring in women regularly and
they'll say well they're all you know
ratchet hoes from the clubs or whatever
like that no disagreement yeah but um
but and so you can
but when you listen to these girls they
all have the same stories i'm i'm
looking for a guy who is you know
the guy's gonna take me on yacht parties
i'm looking for this i'm looking for a
guy who's got money i'm looking for
it seems like they're looking at in you
know sort of towards the future but what
they're not understanding is that at the
at their point of life say like i said
18 to 28 years old they don't realize
that their sexual selectivity is like
the party's going to be over at some
point because they're going to be
replaced by the next cycle of 18 to 28
year olds that come in so you know the
joke is this is you know they called the
store forever 21 not forever 41 right
because you're looking for women are
always looking back at that peak uh that
those peak years because that's when
they had their their the top of their
agency they're at the top of their power
the power curve that i was saying before
and they they constantly look back to
that and as as women go forward i think
there's almost a blue pill for women as
well which is we'd sell women on this
idea of what i call fempowerment and
we've been doing this really since 1970
since the the
sexual revolution
we want to put women into the workplace
we want to uh we want to have special
dispensation for them in colleges we
want to get them into stem fields we
want to give them access to you know
pell grants and all kinds of
ways to sort of you know build them up
put them into the workforce put them
into politics put them into the economy
as much as possible the problem is that
what happens is women end up becoming
the men they want to marry they end up
becoming the quote-unquote alpha female
or the boss babe or whatever it is now
and they can't understand why they can't
find a guy who is their quote unquote
equal who doesn't want to have anything
to do with them catastrophic because
anybody who is better than they are
status wise is not looking for a quote
unquote alpha female they're looking for
the girl who's 23 years old who's
feminine and wants to have you know go
forward and have kids and has you know
say well she's submissive whatever
i
counsel women today who tell me i can't
find a guy i can't find a guy who is uh
my equal but he's got a you know they're
not going to college men are are
enrolling at like 40 versus 60 for women
right now i'm sure you've probably seen
those stats um and
so there's this socio-economic
disparity between men and women right
now that's causing this divide but it's
also this expectation and we expect
women to sort of dumb themselves down so
that they can get with a guy who
you know up to that point they've been
raised on these ideals that they should
never settle that they should never
settle for anything less than the best
and
you know statistically speaking the best
is making 58 more than that woman does
to forestall divorce when a woman gets a
a rise in pay or she gets a you know a
promotion at work that is what
precipitates divorce in uh couples where
they were making the same or or she was
making less and now she's making more
those are simple biological evolutionary
realities so if you enjoyed this little
short segment from the podcast that we
did here's another short segment to
watch or if you want to see the entire
podcast click over here take care
everybody bye-bye
[Music]